you know i want to go back to something
you were talking about with uh women
being more susceptible to to see our crt
and stuff and i'm wondering if that's
due perhaps to
you know the the the the trope of women
being more socially inclined and men
being more like physically inclined or
you know goal oriented you know what i
mean
yeah more uh
achievement or um
well i think there are it's personality
traits i mean i think this whole concept
of what's mass toxic masculinity is
something that is is sprung out of not
so crt is just you know one branch of
critical theory so there's the critical
gender theory critical race theory uh
critical class theory all of these
things so it's just it is one big
marxist lie at the end of the day but i
think women are more susceptible because
well in general women are more
liberal i mean i said the thing about
the 80s but generally speaking voting
patterns nationally is that women they
you know it's the road to hell is paved
with good intentions and so it always
sounds nice that marxism is this fairy
tale that sounds nice like why why would
like everybody freeze what i'm asking is
it that's i feel like it's inverted i
feel like uh women are more social than
men so they're more likely to vote
democrat because of critical race theory
so so if you look at uh instagram for
instance the women are substantially
more likely to get depressed over likes
and posting images than men do because
there's a social interaction of of being
accepted and you know being cheered on
by your peers so uh i'm not i'm not a
psychologist or an evolutionary
psychologist or a biologist like that so
i don't know exactly if that's true just
something that i've read so i'm
wondering you know when i look at the
poll from vox that showed
70 around 70 percent of millennial women
are democrats
is this because of social behaviors
that men are less likely to be
influenced by
does that result in them yeah
that's interesting i mean i think there
is the group think and the virtue
signaling and the rewards so if you come
out and and
you say i'm you know i'm i'm a 12 year
old girl and i'm going to start getting
testosterone blockers you will get a lot
of instagram likes yeah um you're going
to be cheered you know and it's it's uh
and what if you
are a 13 year old girl and say i was
wrong about that and want to stop
you'll be shunned yeah is there any
evidence that show if women are more
likely to fall into cults than men have
you guys ever looked into that kind of
thing that is a good question well well
what's interesting is that uh there were
within mormonism which we were talking
about because my ancestors helped found
it uh polygamy it's a thing they were i
was just about to mention that's 10
miles
just in general well yeah i think in i i
think for sure in practicing mormonism i
think that's the agreeableness uh jordan
peterson's big five personality traits i
think this agreeableness would be the
one that would make it people kind of
just get up get along go along to get
along yeah well yeah and and refuse to
dissent the dissent descent comes with a
social cost right so yeah so the way the
left and marxism has taken over the the
cultural outputs of media hollywood and
academia
the the
rewards for dissension are
minimizing every day every year so that
might be part of it for sure
tim i think you're onto something i've
i've found multiple articles women are
more likely to be in cults than men
makes sense so this one is just from
steemit so i'm not sure it says it's
from the independent uh i just pulled it
up on google and it says women are more
likely to attend traditional religious
service services and more vulnerable to
joining cults there's a bunch of other
articles uh talking the same thing there
was one about nixium
which uh from the national post that
said women are more susceptible to being
to joining cults and there's another one
from 2014 about brazil and they said
majority of the women around the world
the majority of the people around the
world in cults are women and tribal life
was probably just like a cult you got
your tribal chief
who's the cult leader and then everybody
else and then in some cults or in some
cults and some like tribes cultures
where the word comes from they would
like
all share the the child wearing together
like all the men would have sex with all
the women and they would just no one
knew who the dad was they were just all
as a tribe raised the children very
cult-like it tends to be very effective
very modern day cult like you would
consider that'd be a very weird
polygamist called what we're going to
say sheamus well i think another way of
of analyzing this and the political
differences that we tend to see between
men and women is it seems to be the case
and there are some smaller studies which
have suggested this but men are much
more comfortable with hierarchy than
women are women tend to be more
comfortable in egalitarian that's what
the new york times article was saying is
interesting okay yeah and it makes sense
and so you know there there's a time and
place for both because which is a very
marxist an idea
he got egalitarian promise of marxism
which is actually a lie because they
have their elite party leaders who are
you know by far the the top of the
hierarchy no exactly and so i believe
that there's there's obviously value in
this and i'm you know a firm believer in
complementarianism and that men and
women are different and uh you know our
our strengths sort of complement one
another's weaknesses and vice versa
there are good reasons in some
circumstances to be skeptical of an
authority structure and so it's good
that that is baked into a women
generally in a way that's not baked into
men but also it is often the case where
the authority structure is fine and you
have to submit to it even if it hurts
your ego and in those cases a more male
way so to speak of thinking about the
issue tends to be the better one and
it's really interesting that we can
actually see how that affects people's
voting patterns
well it's interesting you said that
about the hierarchy with with business
because i remember that's something that
jordan peterson has said over and over
because uh you know
women in business are always like you
know men always run business and they're
it's all sexism why you know there's the
pay gap which we know is is mythological
and isn't real but but they they repeat
these lies because it makes them feel
good because there are there are fewer
female ceos
and they're always saying well we need
to have you know a female way of doing
business but what as jordan peterson
says okay if there was an actual
female way to do business versus milway
uh the market would reward this like if
there was a non-hierarchical way to do
business successfully the market would
reward it but it doesn't because it's
not true who is james damore
uh that he was google yeah
and he actually wrote we should change
the way we
we do business here to accommodate women
they call them sexist for it the
weirdest thing to me is that here's a
guy who's saying i recognize that women
you know are in a patriarchy and we
should be more accommodating to them and
they were like burn the witch
or the warlock in this instance yeah the
wizard no but i mean he was saying like
women women work better in different
environments than men so why don't we do
this that or otherwise and they were
like it was a white supremacist
alt-right racist and this is like so
when they agree with you they're racist
when they disagree with you they're
racist
sure it's like a mock being drawn to the
fire they're like come moths come to the
flame and then when they get too close
they're like
you did exactly what we wanted you to do
yeah it was a trick you spouted
and then also if there was a real pay
gap uh there would be no men ever hired
like if you could get the same quality
same caliber same credentialing of a
female worker for whatever
25 percent less hell y'all would be
unemployed except that argument assumes
men and women have the equal if equal
capabilities so i was i always thought
that was interesting because um there's
a video by uh this guy maddox you ever
ever see it the the truth about the wage
gap or whatever he made a long time ago
it's actually really well done and he's
like want to know one one simple reason
why there's no such thing as a payback
pay gap because if there was no company
would ever hire men unless
you had to pay the same but men were
better at the job then they would only
hire men exactly yeah well it's so sad
too that there are people who want to
deny the reality of these differences
because the world is so
beautiful in so many ways and one of the
things that makes it so beautiful is the
contrast between men and women and if we
deny that which makes us weaker when
we're apart we're also foregoing that
which makes us stronger when we come
together or at least acknowledging that
men and women really need each other but
when you want to have this sort of
strange flat
egalitarian marxist style thinking
surrounding gender you lose all that
there isn't any
such thing as a trait which is more
prevalent or common um among men you
wouldn't refer to like the masculine
virtues or feminine virtues or anything
like that
yeah because it's like
celine dion she creates a genderless
line of baby clothes because gender is
just a construct and you know which is
so crazy i went through a really
codependent kind of long-term
relationship about six years so i came
out of it pendulum swung the other way
and i was like i want to be in a
relationship where we're equal where
we're both powerful
face you know alpha we're both you know
equal means the same so i tried to go
that route and it didn't work men and
women aren't the same no we're very
different
and sometimes i think women are not
equipped to play a support role it's not
that the man can't play a support role
but man women are good at it i don't
know if that's in that's a
generalization like the man is the tank
and the woman is the healer yes well
it's all and it's also again this the cc
fans will all uh very easy wow this is
all very biblical so it's going to be
very offensive to people but yeah
there's just a natural law structure to
things where women do look to men for
leadership and women are miserable when
they're with men who won't step up and
take that role they don't say that
they're sounding
that's great it's like here's the thing
here's the thing can you identify as
jordan peterson can i get you right now
yeah absolutely ladies and gentlemen uh
as long as sheamus does identify as dr
jordan peterson then i can write down
that we have we have we had him on the
show that's true well the thing is
whenever you have one of those
relationships where the guy's like she's
the boss i feel so bad for both of them
for both of them no one's happy with
that arena
there might be a situation like why
won't he just step up and do the things
hold on sheamus what you look at lions
right
and the male lion
lays lazes about does nothing the women
do all the work get all the food he eats
whatever he wants first goes back to
sleep and then she has all the babies
he's gotta make no yeah i mean isn't
that what's going on with these guys not
fulfilling but that's the thing and i've
said this before we live in a culture
where women are acting like men and men
are acting like children
and part of the reason women are acting
like men is because the men are acting
like children and someone needs to usurp
that role unfortunately i'm not sure
well the government is that's what's
happening the government
has destroyed for example the black
family absolutely
the the fact that 75 of black babies
pre-welfare were born in two parent
homes and now it's the reverse
what's happened is that uncle sam has
taken over the role of the father the
provider in the home perhaps i mean i've
heard that quite a bit but i wonder if
it's just how about we just address
that first point in whatever form so uh
for instance black lives matter wants to
disrupt the nuclear family i don't i
don't know if we need to come out and be
like welfare specifically other than to
just say hey families are good family
well yeah it's it's the culture it's
it's always a feedback loop but the
culture predicated the policy and then
the policy exacerbated the culture
because it didn't happen overnight
i want to i want to talk about that yeah
that's what i mentioned one more thing
there was actually an analysis i believe
from the brookings institute which is
really fascinating because it said that
the primary reason for the breaking up
of the black family and the fatherless
epidemic which of course we are catching
up to
as well is was actually roe v wade and
the fact that women could get abortions
really subverted the family structure it
was all of it i think it was also just
the normalization with the 60s of the
disruption of you know the drug sex and
rock and roll that uh that basically the
norms of okay let's wait until we're
married before we have sex well yeah
that was totally thrown out the window
so so this this whole era was the in
infantilization of a generation yeah to
be told to live for your for your
pleasures for your short-term gains for
your whims like a child instead of
realizing you've got to roll up your
sleeves and strive for yourself that
trickles down and you know i look at uh
i hear these stories you know your
grandfather he could support a family of
five on a high school education and i'm
just like there's a lot to break down
there in in terms of you know even
immigration and stuff like that but also
these are people who fought in world war
ii and they knew the value of hard work
and they knew what it meant that if you
did not struggle to survive you did not
survive and then you get the next
generation that have all the fruits of
of world war ii the the you know we we
decimated the japanese and german
industries that that you know among a
variety of things our industries explode
our economy is booming we have all of
these babies and they grow up in a world
where everything's handed to them now
i'm very i'm i'm very much uh critical
of overall of the boomer generation yeah
they've extracted a ton of wealth for
themselves they're hoarding all of that
wealth and
yeah i certainly think millennials are a
lost generation too but i think it's it
starts with this and i think it's very
simply
you know you can call it strass how
generational theory you could call it
strong men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make hard times
etc and we're in that hard time phase so
the way i view the boomer generation
some of gen x and millennials as their
children they're they're childlike
generations they don't understand
the real world and by real world i mean
take someone take a human being take
away all of their clothing
and their everything they own and put
them in the middle of the woods
welcome to reality because that's what
life was like but we've created this
bubble of security and safety and
industry and technology and we're all
born into it
imagine starting a video game like
you're playing you know zelda but you
have every weapon and every item you
wouldn't understand what you're earning
in the video game imagine if you're
playing an rpg and your character starts
completely invincible with all of this
power and money you'd be like what am i
doing exactly why am i playing it it
makes the game hard to learn when you
have all the abilities when you start
well and that's no tim i i 10 000
everything you just said i completely
agree with i mean like the word teenager
didn't exist really like the concept of
a teenager a teen
i mean i'm a teen a preteen or whatever
like that didn't really happen i don't
think until the 50s like is the word
teenager in the bible no is it in the
odyssey no like it's a concept it is a
wealthy post-industrialized rich country
spoiled who's living off the backs of of
the greatest generation
you want to get real real uh offensive
to everybody
feminism only exists in secure wealthy
nations absolutely ten thousand percent
it's a luxury it's a luxury item in yeah
well it's a correction mechanism it
redistributes the wealth because once
that society has feminism it starts to
collapse in the societies that actually
have their gender holds together sexual
roles together take over but it's also
the case that with the boomers what's so
tragic about that generation is we look
back on them and when i say we i'm
talking about the common narrative not
necessarily what people here believe
but people look back on them as if they
were this incredible revolutionary
generation that came in and shook the
foundations dude their parents had lived
through the great depression and then
lived through the second world war many
of them fighting in it and even those
who didn't fight it had to struggle
through the hard times of rationing and
then with all of the wisdom that their
parents had accumulated they turned
around and were like we need to give
them our wisdom they're like mom and dad
no i'm gonna go to a rock and roll
concert and have sex with strangers and
we look back on this as if it we call it
a a revolution it was the sexual
revolution and that's great if you
understand the term revolution the way i
do which is in a negative connotation
but to glorify that kind of behavior it
was a generation of spoiled teenagers
who ended up ruining their inheritance
no totally and it's not progressive at
all it is regressive talking about like
what you were talking about our
ancestors living in
huts and you know i have native american
ancestors so i can say this uh you know
it's it's
savage it's it's living in uh you know
societies that are uh you know
promiscuous that's that's it's
regressive to go back to that
marriage was a is an it was an
innovation
for women i i don't i'm not as negative
on feminism as as you are sheamus you
know no one is so you know when i say
you know getting a little getting
offensive
i think it's a fact that if you look
across the world at all of these
countries the countries that are least
secure it's very difficult for women to
to have rights to have power because
war conflict aggression but i i think we
need we need a healthy balance i
certainly think there's been instances
of you know uh men controlling too much
and women being less involved but now
we're going the other way where our
society is becoming overtly feminine i
think there needs to be a happy medium
of of a matriarch and a patriarchal kind
of approach to things like a mother and
a father there's a meme where
someone's like he's standing on a cliff
and he says
accompany boards should have a man and a
woman and everyone's like yeah and then
he goes a child should have a mother and
a father and they're like
but i'm like no i i think that it that
that it scales and there is a benefit to
a masculine and a feminine view and if
it skews too much in one direction you
get you know authoritarianism in
different ways yeah well and i would say
and this is part of why i still
disregard feminism even though i
absolutely agree that in many parts of
the world women are treated like dirt
and also throughout history men have not
always treated women well obviously
humans are a fallen species but in those
systems it's not that you have a
patriarchy it's that you have an
extremely disordered patriarchy where
the men are effeminate they're not
virtuous they don't stand up for their
women and protect them they treat them
poorly because their conception of the
the relationship between men and women
is women need to give give give and i
need to take take take whereas the way
men are supposed to operate is as giving
and women
are to operate essentially as receptive
based on any kind of natural law vision
of the world thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you